as 1905 dawned the soon-to-be 26
year-old Albert Einstein faced life as a
failed academic most physicists of the
time would have scoffed at the idea that
this minor civil servant could have much
to contribute to science yet within the
following year
Einstein would publish not one not two
not three but four extraordinary papers
each on a different topic that were
destined to radically transform our
understanding of the universe the myth
that Einstein had failed math is just
that he had mastered calculus on his own
by the age of 15 and done well at both
his Munich secondary school and at the
Swiss Polytechnic where he studied for a
math and physics teaching diploma but
skipping classes to spend more time in
the lab and neglecting to show proper
deference to his professors had derailed
his intended career path passed over
even for a lab assistant position he had
to settle for a job at the Swiss Patent
Office obtained with the help of a
friend's father working six days a week
as a patent clerk Einstein still managed
to make some time for physics discussing
the latest work with a few close friends
and publishing a couple of minor papers
it came as a major surprise when in
March 1905 he submitted a paper with a
shocking hypothesis despite decades of
evidence that light was a wave
Einstein proposed that it could in fact
be a particle showing that mysterious
phenomena such as the photoelectric
effect could be explained by his
hypothesis the idea was derided for
years to come but Einstein was simply 20
years ahead of his time wave particle
duality was slated to become a
cornerstone of the quantum revolution
two months later in May I'm Stein
submitted a second paper this time
tackling the centuries-old question of
whether atoms actually exist though
certain theories were built on the idea
of invisible atoms
some prominent scientists still believed
them to be a useful fiction rather than
actual physical objects but Einstein
used an ingenious argument showing that
the behavior of small particles randomly
moving around in a liquid known as
Brownian motion could be precisely
predicted by the collisions of millions
of invisible atoms experiments soon
confirmed Einsteins model and atomic
skeptics threw in the towel the third
paper came in June for a long time
Einstein had been troubled by an
inconsistency between two fundamental
principles of physics the
well-established principle of relativity
going all the way back to Galileo stated
that absolute motion could not be
defined yet electromagnetic Theory also
well-established asserted that absolute
motion did exist the discrepancy and his
inability to resolve it left Einstein in
what he described as a state of psychic
tension but one day in May after he had
mulled over the puzzle with his friend
Michele Besso
the clouds parted I Stein realized that
the contradiction could be resolved if
it was the speed of light that remained
constant
regardless of reference frame while both
time and space were relative to the
observer
it took Einstein only a few weeks to
work out the details and formulate what
came to be known as special relativity
the theory not only shattered our
previous understanding of reality but
would also pave the way for technologies
ranging from particle accelerators to
the global positioning system one might
think that this was enough but in
September of fourth paper arrived as a
by the way follow-up to the special
relativity paper Einstein had thought a
little bit more about his theory and
realized it also implied that mass and
energy one apparently solid and the
other supposedly if the
were actually equivalent and their
relationship could be expressed in what
was to become the most famous and
consequential equation in history e
equals MC squared Einstein would not
become a world-famous icon for nearly
another 15 years it was only after his
later general theory of relativity was
confirmed in 1919 by measuring the
bending of starlight during a solar
eclipse that the press would turn him
into a celebrity but even if he had
disappeared back into the Patent Office
and accomplished nothing else after 1905
those four papers of his miracle year
would have remained the gold standard of
startling unexpected genius
you